from private dates at home to exotic
trips in Africa and talk of having
children we're looking at everything
Prince Harry and Megan Markel have said
about their relationship on spillin the
royalty hi guys i'm lauren zima Prince
Harry and Megan Markel have given just a
few select interviews about their love
so we are breaking down the specifics on
everything they've said because we're
obsessed their love was secretive for
months but after lots of rumors and
speculation Megan finally broke her
silence in the October 2017 issue of
Vanity Fair saying simply quote we are
two people who are really happy and in
love and not long after we got their
first joint interview in November Harry
and Megan got engaged and gave an
insightful sit down to the BBC / Royal
tradition fans found out how Harry
proposed just just an amazing surprise
it was so sweet and natural and very
romantic he got on Whitney yes yes that
was about a year and a half after they
were introduced by a mutual friend it
was I think about three maybe four weeks
later that I managed to persuade her to
come and join me in Botswana after a
private trip to Africa bonded them
absolutely amazing to get to know as
quickly as I did Megan and Harry started
a long-distance relationship she was
still working on her show suits in
Canada so how'd they make it work well
they never spent more than two weeks
apart it was just a choice right I think
that very early on and we realized we
were going to commit to each other
and we knew we had to invest the time in
the energy and to keep the relationship
secret they had to do things backwards
cooking dinner with Justin service by
ourselves of a little cottage robbing
and being seen in public so we have we
reversed the whole process which is it's
it's it's provided different
opportunities and has made us a hell of
a lot closer in a shorter space of time
like kind of a blessing in disguise the
adoring pair also explained how they
knew this was it
both of us have passions for wanting to
make change change for good that's one
of the first things we started talking
about when we met was just the different
things that we wanted to do in the world
and how passionate we were about seeing
change I think that was that's what got
date 2 in the books from Megan and Harry
revealed they've gotten to know each
other's families and that their own
children will come quote in the near
future since getting engaged Megan and
Harry have made several appearances
together but we still haven't seen them
speak much we did get one more taste of
their dynamic in February with this
adorable joke the last thing you
disagreed on how to resolve it we're a
fantastic team we know real well that's
everything we know straight from the
mouths of Royals what do you guys think
of Prince Harry and Megan Markel's love
for each other and how soon do you think
they'll have kids we'd love some more
royal babies let me know what you think
Sharia
you
[Music]